so in this video I wanted to talk about
the beta oxidation of unsaturated fatty
acids and we're going to use a specific
example of an even-numbered 1:18 carbon
polyunsaturated fatty acids specifically
coming from Manoli 8 which is viñoly
Ocoee now two polyunsaturated fatty
acids are two carbon-carbon double bonds
and they are specifically sis delta nine
insists delta twelve because this is
carbon number nine this one's 10 and
this one is 12 and 13 so it's telling
you where those carbon-carbon double
bonds exist okay one starts at 9 and
goes to 10 the other starts at 12 and go
to 13 since Delta 9 system 12 and of
course just because they're both system
o bonds so pay attention to this it's
gonna be pretty important in certain
instances but now what I want to do is
talk about how this is similar to and
how it's different from beta oxidation
of saturated fatty acids now if you just
look at this fatty acyl Co way that
we're starting with here this linoleic
OE this first portion of the molecule
pretty much looks like a saturated fatty
acid and so you might expect that that
portion could just undergo regular beta
oxidation and that actually is the case
so we're gonna have three rounds of beta
oxidation in a specific example before
things get kind of weird
so we'll clip off a lot one we'll clip
off in acetyl co a there one two three
rounds of beta oxidation and we'll make
one two three uh pseudocode ways that we
can see here here and here of course
also make the fadh2s
and nadh and those in those reactions as
well okay now once we have that happen
we ended up you know having the carbonyl
here and the coenzyme a right there and
we get the we lose those six carbons
right from those three two carbon units
of acetyl co ways and we end up going
from an 18 carbon unit or 18 carbon
molecule to a 12 carbon molecule which
is shown here doe deck 12
die in oil right I to
dying to Eanes eknoll right co a now
we've seen in oil co a before you know l
co a is something that we make in
regular beta oxidation the thing is
about the inalco a that we make in
regular bit operation this has a trends
you know peanut oil co a and it's a
trans delta ii so here we have two
system bonds and they are assisted l23
and cysts of the six we're not really
concerned too much whether it's uh still
to six cuz it's further away from the
carbonyl carbon we're more concerned
about this third one for now or the one
on the third carbon rather what's the
situation with that well normally when
we have the in oil co a in beta
oxidation it's between the alpha and
beta carbons and here this is carbon
number two here's our alpha carbon and
this is our beta carbon normally
normally the double bond is right here
between and it's trans but here it's
between three and four and it's cysts
and that's a problem because that can't
go through regular beta oxidation so we
need to actually move that we need to
move this double bond here and make it
trans and that's actually what's done
that's what we get here and move that i
wanna make it trans but that can't be
done by our regular beta oxidation
enzyme that has to be done by something
entirely different so we knew and that's
actually going to be done by delta 3
delta ii ian oil co a isomerase so what
does that do is that that takes that
that double bond from start from that
that odd number starting carbon right
that's where the double bond starts and
moves it right there so it's it moves it
from being a cyst delta three double
bond to a trans delta 2 double bond
alright so delta 3 does it sue in oil co
a rise was acting on isomerase it just
makes a nice summer now once it does
that we have this annoying now this you
know elko a is what we would typically
see in a beta oxidation right this is
the alpha carbon
this is the beta carbon it's a trans in
oil Co a that can be acted upon by
regular beta oxidation enzymes so we'll
have the second the second reaction of
beta oxidation which is the hydration
and then followed by the second
oxidation followed by the cleavage
reaction all as normal but notice
obviously I'll stop it and come back to
that in just a second but notice that in
creating that that that you know L Co a
here this is typically created by the
first step of beta oxidation this is
usually made usually made by the a so Co
a dehydrogenase right in the first
oxidation step but that's not the case
here you know what's also made there as
an fadh2 so we don't make that here we
don't make that with this isomerization
reaction so we would normally create an
fadh2 here but we don't when this
isomerase reaction goes but we do have
the rest of these reactions of beta
oxidation and so we go from that 12
carbon unit or that 12 carbon molecule
why we still have to hydratase that's
catalyzing the hydration then to make
that beta hydroxy s with Co a and then
the second oxidation which turns that
into a bit of keto isoko a and in the
thiolase which Cleaves off the the
acetyl co a here right to make to give
us this 10 carbon a soak away all right
now so as far as what happened there all
we all that happened really that was
different was having missed out on an
fadh2 because we had to move that double
bond okay now we have this 10 carbonyl
Co a and it's a syst
Delta for assist Delta for carbon-carbon
double bond okay so what's gonna happen
is actually for the first part over here
this is just an acyl Co a
so the first oxidation can actually
occur we'll get an fadh2 acyl Cody
hydrogenase catalyzes that reaction no
problem now we have this diagonal KO a
where we have this trans Delta 2
right here which is what we normally
have but we also have this cystal 2 4
that's going to make things ugly if we
don't take care of it right away
so now something's gonna be a little bit
different
you